[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the oppressed foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
white
get the head down
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
supreme
[Applause]
huh
your dignity
[Applause]
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
this is [ __ ] up what is actually
got pretty nervous for this thing felt
like i had something to prove
to myself to you whoever the [ __ ]
huh
that was enough in that case here
take it as a souvenir
you sure won't play without you
just wouldn't be the same see what
you're doing here
but i still plan on playing
[Music]
so
johnny oh he's
gone isn't he yeah
yeah but he can still hear you thanks
but not in the mood for hovering tables
and voices from beyond the grave right
now
maybe you should hang on to this
actually
you shouldn't have really the very gun
i tried to shoot johnny with when he
broke into my house
meaning you tried to shoot me yeah
and early never mind
cool i feel like i fell asleep
woke up 50 years later back to work then
take care of me i'll be in touch
well it wasn't so bad was it too bad
care's gone off
in case he had somewhere to be badly
probably writing a new song as we speak
isn't that what you wanted to make him
feel better
better but not that good johnny don't
ever leave me again i can't live without
you
a little of that could go a long way
hope that's it for last requests maybe
now you get a chance to do what you will
gotta go talk to hanako
fast okay your choice
let's go